594 one minutes the bootleg cab show
live on the phone right now one of my
favorite artists in the game chance the
rapper chance what's going on bro what's
up my name man i'm chillin bruh first
things first you've had a great year man
i feel like um every festival you're
you're like you're just all I just you
everywhere man how are you feeling I
feel good man I have had a very blessed
ah what here so far uh yeah let's talk
about the the tour first of all I saw
you're gonna be coming to town on the on
the Family Matters tour yeah which is
gonna be dope what made you pick the
lineup I saw dramas on the tour talk
about this tour compared to I think the
last time I saw you was in Phoenix and
like I think was 2013 which was on that
was a strap to her yeah yeah yeah this
one's a little different uh it's called
the family medicine cuz it's just me and
a few of my friends we're bringing our
drum who's killing it you know
intercepted is chacha join in as new EP
we got metro boomin we just killed his
ear and say the whole albums or so sure
yes yeah Tokyo who's going crazy offered
me save money project is yes it's
awesome to and we also got Titus say oh
you know some of the dates and they're
all this blood rage right now too so
yeah it's straight straight family loves
straight people that us that I've been
creating with and been working with for
a while and we were just like yeah let's
get together and just have fun on the
tour yeah don't man um you know I back
in 2013 like everybody was was was
really talking about like you know there
was a bidding war for chance the rapper
you were doing you did the record with
bieber and and you've really kind of
sustained everything independently um
for a long period of time and you're
you're thriving are you is that even
something you're even interested in now
ever ever working like with it with a
full major not at this point you know
right now I like I said I'm focused on
fun I'm making the best music anybody
can make being around my family and uh
yeah i mean like i don't i don't really
like see a huge problem with with you
know signing a record deal but right now
it's about me
in our own decisions and keeping that
family oriented up so chance I saw that
you have a little bee album you and
little be recorded a whole album is this
real life is this true it's true up that
I is 0 first it's the truth it's all
done and it's a masterpiece so you and
little be recorded how many tracks is
the album is it like a full-fledged
album is it you know EP wow how many
tracks did you guys do together I'll
tell you I'll tell you it's a
full-fledged album I can't tell you how
many tracks on it I can't tell you how
many bars we go back and forth I can't
tell you about the monologue I can't
tell you about the features it's a
classic you know right now a bootleg
that that's what son all right well I
mexica you know I've been known to be a
little bit supporter over the years so
I'm pretty excited I'm pretty excited um
hey how proud are you were your man Vic
Mensa you know i've been i've been good
friend of Vic's since you know kids
these days was popping and you know I
feel like a lot of people always kind of
compare you to cuz you guys came up
together I know you guys are really
close friends I'm and yes you guys are
both in great places how proud are you
with that kind man that's my brother and
I'm saying uh he's been just making me
super proud as of late and you know we
wear the same super close friends and we
push each other to go hard at you know
everything he's doing right now is just
making me hungrier oh and yeah I mean
just like I got I got love for his whole
team you know I know you know camo be of
course ya can tell me that yeah that's
my boy and I'm addictive just been
taking taking flight lately yeah yeah
that's dope man um so the family matters
tour it's gonna be I believe you're
gonna be out here in October um what
what has been your favorite live
performance you've ever done I'm gonna
tell you this I saw you uh also uh when
you were on tour with Mac Miller and
action and I was tripping balls cuz I
ate an edible and it was like one of the
work I mean it was like one of the best
worst concert experiences of my life but
that was probably my favorite time
seeing you because I'm pretty sure
Garfield the cat was on stage with you I
was like hallucinating like I call some
crazy well but what was that one
performance cuz you brought out people
with you you've you know you brought out
Kanye for the kids like you've done a
lot of things what's what's been that
one line
I live moment that sticks out in your
head is like the d1 yeah I in my sound
bite us because it was so recent but
recently i played pitchfork festival in
chicago yes and in the hometown brought
out Kirk Franklin's a gospel legend I
saw that had my full my foot dance team
working with one of the best
choreographers in the world Ian Eastwood
work with some of the best choir
directors interested a full-fledged like
ensemble piece play for everybody and
enter this day that's why that the most
moving parts at hearing since I'm the
most memorable you know just pieces
being performed on say stuff that we
don't always get to do some old
materials new material that was just
that was a nice to me and I still you
know just want to go back to that moment
and and you know what's been real cool
is like I've just been noticing a lot of
the stuff you've been doing for um just
for like the youth in Chicago because I
feel like I feel like Chicago is
starting to at least and in the hip-hop
world the the more positive things are
coming to the forefront as far as
perception for you know cuz you know 22
years ago it was all chief keeping
nothing against chief keef he's doing
this thing but I feel like a lot of that
drill stuff a lot of that negative
violent stuff is kind of taking a seat
back to stuff like yourself and and
vicks um but you do the open mic thing
and from what I understand that's like a
tribute to someone who you knew right
who was like who used to like being a
neighborhood helping out the kids so I I
grew up on the boat you finish the cargo
and in the open mic scene and when I was
a kid I used to go to this youth center
I in downtown Chicago on this guy named
whether Mike was uh my mentor all
through growing up and he introduced me
sick to poetry and introduced me to all
the light set up I passed away last year
at the end of last year and uh me and
some logistics they grew up and I only
want to say kids were all grown now
bring some of the people I grew up with
and that same program came back together
to to put together a new free open mic
for kids associate by myself in this guy
named Malcolm London and you know every
every time we do when we bring out a
guest speakers from Chicago so we did
Kanye that one time with the Hannibal
Buress King louia use a discography and
all such people that you know really you
know grew up in the and it's been
yet cuz they wanted and uh you know just
got them to be working with
kids on our organic level and so yeah
that's one of the brightest things that
we got going on right now to do that we
also work with chicago park district's
we just did a field trip today with a
bunch of six and seven-year-olds six to
thirteen year old was don't man and uh
yeah I was just working on that was
outside there and uh and we just been
you know trying to trying to trying to
built the city up from from within you
know stand out from the outside not yeah
well um number really back and working
within it yo uh my life surprise like
that yeah that's big um I saw you
tweeted not too long ago the surf itunes
music stats which were crazy six hundred
and eighteen thousand downloads 10 over
10 million singles uh that's i mean
that's like that's like crazy but i like
what made you want to put out the surf
project for free on iTunes yes I think
it's all a part of a larger jab at a
huge infrastructure of music and the way
that people you know proceeded being
released at you know music is music with
or without a price tag on it here I'm
saying it I wanted people that I just
want everybody to be able to experience
and I wanted to make a statement from
inside the itunes store because I could
give it away for free anywhere but I
think they've never wait for free on I
just said something about the way Apple
views music says something about the way
the world views okay i think was just
the best way for anybody to get it how
you feeling about this drake record to
drop last night have you heard that back
to back yeah it goes crazy yeah you
messing with it what do you think like
like about the whole beef I mean um
obviously you're probably fans of both
guys I mean both artists are incredible
you know I think the ghost riding thing
a lot of people have something to say
about that what are your thoughts on all
that yeah I like music a lot so you're
in feel like I like hearing music oh I
think thief isn't necessarily my forte
right um but I know I know them and they
I think there are I think they're cool
peoples and I think it's more of a you
know a situation isolated situation that
just paying music song I'm so I'm in
full support of I like the fact that
they make a music back and forth and say
it has exciting people who are fans of
yours and fans of Kanye I mean that's
something that I've
like it's been an inevitable thing where
you and Kanye collaborate on music
whether it's his album your album have
you guys worked on music together we've
definitely set down in the studio and
and and just by yeah I'll say what you
want to get too specific about about
ideas or isolating that your music it's
a bigger project print but but yeah we
love the same music when we sit down in
the studio are we talking private and uh
and yet that's that's that's what it is
when's the next chance to wrap a project
dropping or you have you got new music
ready or what mr. finest you asked about
it yet I got a single coming very slow
can't say the name of it i can say
you'll probably hear it first in tampa
with blue LED kev-o probably hear you
some type of exclusive let's do that
let's do it let's do it that sounds like
a plan man well look man the tour's
gonna be crazy I'm really like proud of
you man from where you've come like I
remember my boy Enzo told me about you
yeah bro like I think it was like we're
at a Grammy party in like twenty twelve
and it was like right after the 10 days
taped head I think it was just dropping
and and is it was like yo fam you got it
you got to listen to chance the rapper
that's the next dude and sure enough he
was he way he wasn't lying bruh you know
I appreciate both of you guys man and I
appreciate you recommend they want so
yeah for sure brother we'll look man um
let's get into a record I'm gonna let
you introduce anything off surf you want
you want to introduce or any record man
whether it's cleaning and I'll clean it
up so I'll let you introduce on it this
next one is 101 and sample the long as
the lake has its list like these when
Buster ons is the nominee let's do a
chance to rapper my brother I'll talk to
you soon man i'll see you in San for a
couple months I'll see you there